[Music]  this blink and you missed it  oscar's moment turned into a meme Sunday  night everyone wondering what was  Jennifer Garner thinking well now we  kinda know thanks to Jen Congrats to  shape of water maybe I should date a  fish hey Jimmy Kimmel what's in your  wallet wait where's my wallet  to work with Lena Dunham wait did I sign  a nudity waiver yes garner herself  provided some funny commentary over the  clip it's something she does pretty  regularly on Instagram though usually  it's over  ballet videos Indiana Woodward's joy  spills out every time she hits the stage  workplace with her dog Luna I think  she's obsessed with her dog  it's like Instagram goals I'm just gonna  say you know what I mean  [Music]